gentlemen afterwards we will you'll have
time you can go up to the microphone we
have about 10 minutes left so if you do
have questions go ahead and line up
behind the microphone I promise I'll get
to you just enhancing my martyr
complex he not a jihadist martyr with
bom I don't know I I do want to ask
question marks Robert Spencer because
this is important and he probably gets
his criticism all the time um your books
are seen as provocative by a lot of
people and the doctors making the point
that there are moderate segments of of
uh Muslims and that what you do in fact
is that you you uh polarize them that
that books like uh the politically
incorrect guide to Islam and the
Crusades actually takes those moderates
and U polarizes them and makes them even
more uh pro-islamic or even Pro
terrorists or if anything they just drop
out of the debate which could be even
worse how do you respond to that Robert
well actually I already have uh I uh
mentioned before you can't fix what you
would admit is broken you can't reform
what you would admit needs reforming any
Muslim who genuinely rejects the
elements of Islam that I'm speaking
about shouldn't have any problem with my
speaking about them uh as a matter of
fact I take it as a as a kind of an
index as to whether a reformer is
sincere or is a deceiver if if he
professes offense at these things
because the uh the the situation is that
you have people who are claiming that
these elements of Islam do not exist and
as I explained before I I don't think
that that's reform at all uh just to
pretend that they don't exist might be
very comforting to westerners who don't
know whether they exist or not but they
will not keep the jihadists who know
very well that these elements of Islam
exist from continuing to exploit them
and so they have to speak about these
things forthrightly I also think it's
beyond absurd to think that if you have
a Muslim who appor Jihad violence and
Islamic supremacism that if I speak
about these things he will suddenly
Embrace Jihad violence and Islamic
supremacism uh also I want to point out
that Dr Peterson and I both wish to blow
on the Embers of the reform the very
small groups and individuals as he
points out or as he acknowledges that
are working to change what is in Islam
and to mitigate these violent elements
but here again I do not believe that can
be done simply by uh sugarcoating the
harsh realities of the situation but by
confronting them and I appeal again to
the uh historical analogy of the
Protestant Reformation Protestant
reformers did not say the church doesn't
teach transubstantiation and Papal
Authority and anybody who says so is a
hate monger and is going to make me
become a
Catholic and that's the Absurd situation
we're in today no let me just say that
that by portraying this as some people
do a presentation I heard yesterday I
think essentially hinted at this uh
presenting this as some sort of war
between Christianity and Islam between
the west and Islam we do sort of force
some people who who are Muslims
believing Muslims if they if they
believe the war is against Islam and
remember a lot of people over there it's
it's not so much what they it's not so
much what the facts of of the case
really are it's what they believe that
may or may not be so that can affect
their their at toward things if they see
the West as as engaged in a war against
Islam they will line up with Islam the
enemy of my
enemy so on so forth that's an excellent
point doctor we have several guests who
want to ask a question so go ahead and
step up and ask your
question both of the speakers have
stated that there are small minorities
within them I'm sorry sir speak up just
a little bit both of the speakers have
stated that there are small minorities
within Islam who are moderate it seems
to me that the extremists have terrorize
the moderates to the point where they
are totally powerless and have are
unwilling to to speak up could you
comment please yeah that's quite so not
only do they appeal to they make their
appeal within the Islamic communities
that is the jihadists make their appeal
within Islamic communities on the basis
of their Islamic authenticity on the
basis of making saying that they
represent true Islam Real Islam and
anybody who does not wage Jihad against
the West in some form not necessarily
violent form but in some way trying to
help the effort is not authentic Muslim
not only do they do that but they also
uh pronounce the people who reject that
the Muslims who reject these ideas to be
apostate and apostates of course
according to Muhammad's own command if
anybody changes his religion kill him
and according to all the schools of
Islamic law here again and all the
Orthodox sects of Islam apostates must
be executed now this doesn't mean that
every apostate will be executed somebody
has to care enough to carry out the
sentence but the sentence is there and
it does intimidate moderate Muslims it
is used to intimidate moderate Muslims
I'd like to point out also this is
happening right here in the United
States in Tulsa Oklahoma there was a
Muslim a very courageous man who wrote A
oped in the local paper denouncing ama
Bin Laden whereupon he was expelled from
his mosque in Tulsa
Oklahoma and so if you think that the
Muslims in the United States are free
entirely from these ideas remember that
shikh Muhammad hasham kabani himself a
Muslim a Sufi which is as Dr Peterson
said and accused me of not believing a
relatively peaceful sect uh he testified
before State Department opened for him
as long ago as
1999 that 80% of the mosques in the
united states are under the control of
extremists this makes it very difficult
for uh peaceful Muslims and genuine
reformers to make any Headway Dr
Peterson same question how do you
marginalize the extremist and uh and
encourage the moderates oh I think it's
very difficult and I'm not sure how much
we can really do because once people are
branded Western agents their
effectiveness within the Muslim
Community is doomed I might say by the
way there is another way of reading the
uh U though I agree that that uh the
standard reading within the Islamic
community of the prohibition against
apostasy is there that that it deserves
the death penalty there's another way of
reading that the word that's used for
apostasy is also related to the word for
rebellion in the early days of Islam
uhad was was not only apostasy it was
actually sedition it was Rebellion
against legitimate legal Authority which
was punishable by death I think that
this now rests on Miss reading but
unfortunately it's a widespread in this
reading unanimous we have time for one
last question sorry ladies and gentlemen
it's a quick debate thank you very much
for your question sir sir quick question
for the
panel isn't this really about a search
for Power and and whether it's dressed
up as religion or whether it's dressed
up as nationalism looking at your
example excellent question question we
have one minute left panelists we have
non-muslims have absolutely no right to
wield the Reigns of power in any part of
God's Earth and if they do the Believers
are under the obligation to dislodge
them from That Power by any means
possible that is a quotation from Malana
mudi who was who died in 1979 he was the
uh founder of jamat islami which is
still the largest islamist political
party in Pakistan and that is the basis
on the basis of the Quran and so on that
there's no right to for non-muslims to
have political power and it is on that
basis that they're fighting today Dr
Peterson is this a power grab uh I'm I'm
sure it is and I think religion is an
incredibly powerful symbol system and
it's obviously something that resonates
in the Middle East I might note by the
way that despite the fact that in theory
supposedly according to maudi it's
illegal for a non-muslim to exercise
power uh the prime minister of Egypt in
the medieval Islamic period was often
Christian many of the wiers in medieval
Islamic Spain were Jewish ladies and
gentlemen
because they were Jewish and
nevertheless 4,000 people killed in
Granada in 1066 we're going to have to
cut it there it's a long debate